every time i put a healthy recipe
together a healthy dish it needs a bit
of a treat so this is a lovely stunning
get up and go fresh granola first thing
in the morning the treat here
is in that little baby
honey
so that sweetens it
so just start off with 200 ml
of delicious honey
into a pan just to warm up in she goes
now
i know these are a chef's favorite but
it makes all the difference especially
for breakfast a fresh
vanilla pod and i think of the way that
i use herbs to add
flavor to soups and salads
i'd like to think the vanilla does
exactly the same
scrape out all those wonderful seeds in
now
the staple of the granola
is the oats
[Music]
next
puff rice delicious
crunchy
but light
and fluffy next add wheat bran and your
seeds pumpkin sunflower and linseed
and then almonds
incredible
that nice heavy weight
from the nut bunch
now bring the honey to the boil
slowly drizzle that amazing honey
in
give that a really good mix coat the
granola with the hot honey just slowly
churn it
using the outside of the bowl
you can see it just getting nice and
sticky
once the granola is completely coated in
honey it's ready to bake
now spread the mix on baking paper i'm
gonna season it lightly with a touch of
salt on top
the salt throughout
dries up the oats and the honey will
roast
color and glaze
the granola
nice into the oven for 25 to 30 minutes
[Music]
10 minutes into the cooking simply run a
spoon across the top to turn the mix and
ensure it's crunchy all over
you smell that light
roast look at the color
honestly look it's crispy
it's delicious
now i'm going to tart it up and put some
lovely dried cranberries that just gives
us chewy
sweet flavor delicious
and then finally
these beautiful berries
goji berries goji berries are high in
antioxidants and have been eating china
for centuries for their healing
properties but you can add any dried
fruit you like the cranberry and the
goji berries gives it that nice chewy
rich texture
to the granola
now this is the best way
to store it it looks incredible
really incredible
look at that
that
eat well stay well
right
milk
my homemade crunchy granola it looks
good tastes good and it's packed with
healthy grains superfood berries and
seeds it's incredibly good for you too a
breakfast for champions
for my ultimate light lunch a beautiful
quinoa salad with amazing textures and
fresh aromatic flavors to excite the
palette
add one part pre-rinse quinoa to two
parts cold water
if you're not using pre-rinsed the
quinoa grains should be soaked before
use to remove their bitter coating
bring to a simmer and cook for about 20
minutes until the water is absorbed
spoon the cooked quinoa onto a plate and
spread out to cool
[Music]
meanwhile dry roast flaked almonds in a
frying pan
once golden add raisins
chopped mint
and spring onions
peel strips of skin from a whole
cucumber to make stripes
then remove the seeds and chop into half
moon slices
add half cherry tomatoes and the cooled
quinoa
and gently mix in with your fingers
[Music]
season with salt and pepper
dress with a good squeeze of lime and
drizzle of olive oil
finish with a few fresh mint leaves
spicy mexican soup it's hearty delicious
robust but served with some tortillas
and a wonderful salsa it's almost like a
complete meal in one
starting with some finely chopped red
onions for my soup
let's get some heat going early these
are chipotle so they're smoky rich they
don't come with any warning signal and
these are seriously hot so be
adventurous
but beware
a nice teaspoon
of toasted cumin
oregano dried
now start frying off spices the heat
you'll see the chilies start swelling up
delicious
garlic
be quite generous on the oil because
that helps to blow out the chili
right now those onions and garlic
are on fire
we're going to balance the sort of heat
from the chipotle with sugar
turn up the heat
and really start caramelizing that sugar
and the chili
gives off the most amazing
aroma
next fry up a tablespoon of tomato puree
add a can of chopped tomatoes
cook kidney beans and vegetable or
chicken stock to cover
there's something quite exciting about
big and bold flavors because in the
restaurants you have to be somewhat
controlled you can't go crazy
so
cooking these kind of dishes at home
gives me that kind of release chilis
particularly when they're dried continue
to swell and release their heat as
they're cooked so the longer you cook
your dish the hotter it will be
[Music]
but it's not as powerful it needs to be
yet
and every five six seven eight minutes
that's gonna get stronger
hotter and more delicious
bring that up to the ball and cook that
out for 15 minutes
whilst i allow the chili heat to infuse
i'm going to crack on with quick crunchy
tortilla chips and a fabulously fresh
and spicy tomato salsa known in mexico
as pico de gallo
start by finely dicing three ripe
tomatoes
one or two deceded fresh jalapeno
peppers
and half a red onion
then chop a good handful of fresh
coriander
add the juice from two limes
salt and pepper
and a drizzle of extra virgin olive oil
for the tortilla chips rub a little
olive oil onto six large shop bought
wheat wraps
sprinkle with smoked paprika and gently
massage in
cut each wrap into triangles and spread
them onto a baking tray
bake for three to four minutes in a
preheated oven 180 degrees until golden
brown and leave to cool
to complete my mexican lunch i need to
finish my deliciously fragrant spicy
soup
[Music]
the spice is there
it is
absolutely spot on
now for the cooling down process
the mexicans are brilliant at building
layer upon layer of flavor with
delicious chilis and spices but they're
also experts at tempering their dishes
with cooling ingredients like avocado
sour cream and cheese that's why you can
take that amount of chili you've got a
spoon of richness spice and all of a
sudden avocados
almost like a little fire blanket over
those chillies
to further counter the chilli heat
mexicans use a rich tangy crumbly cheese
but i'm sprinkling on lancashire which
is a great british substitute
and last but not least
cooling fresh coriander one delicious
spicy mexican soup
serve that with your tortilla chips and
your pico de gallo salsa
a phenomenal blend of textures and
layers and spice and creaminess
big bold and delicious